do you have anything to share button
ain't no house of encouragement or
whatnot to the new branch of linguistics
students welcome to linguistics try a
little bit of everything don't be afraid
to ask questions about anything and
again find what works for you and run
with it so I think if you have ever had
any interest in language and how it
works and how the people around you use
it then you should at least try taking a
linguistics course if you've taken a
linguistics course and have found any
aspect of it interesting then I would
say go on keep pushing yourself a little
bit further and that can mean taking
classes in linguistics and following up
on those particular topic areas but it
can also mean going out and finding
people whether that's us as professors
or other students who are engaged in
linguistic work and finding out about
what it is that they do on a daily basis
I still believe that you have to find
your passion and you can only do that by
looking inside of you and listening to
languages language is your passion and
figuring a question that drives yeah one
of the most exciting things about
linguistics and language research in
general is that there is so much to do
and not that many people doing it what
you have as a speaker of a language or
of languages is already expert knowledge
in the field and so it's amazing how
that can give you insights that you can
already bring to the table and add to
the knowledge of language in general as
a field you should do what you love to
do and you should not worry am I going
to get a job in this because you can
create your own future
I can't wait sound idealistic but
there's no point studying something you
don't like and there's no point getting
a job you don't like you just have to do
something you like undergraduates have
like you know this little time to kind
of not you know worry about mortgages
and families and you know and ailing
relatives and you know and state of the
world you know there's still time to
think about what you are doing why you
are doing it what the world is like Who
am I where am i where am I going okay
and explore intellectual curiosity if
you can find that space to do that do it
and if it takes you into linguistics go
there
you